en este vídeo quiero explorar como la
tasa de intercambio flotante podría en
teoría resolver los desequilibrios de
comercio y para este ejemplo
simplificado vamos a suponer que la tasa
de intercambio entre el yuan chino y el
dólar estadounidense es de 6 yuanes por
un dólar y también con propósitos de
simplificación imaginaremos que china
solo exporta una cosa a eeuu y eso son
hornos de microondas y a 6 yuanes por
dólar el fabricante chino lo venderá en
eeuu por 50 dólares cada uno y a ese
precio hay una demanda de estos hornos
en eeuu de un millón de unidades también
voy a suponer que lo único que exporta a
eeuu a china es software y ahí la
demanda es de 2 millones de unidades si
se venden a 60 yuanes cada una
veamos cuál será la demanda para cada
una de las monedas para cada uno de los
fabricantes
el fabricante chino de aquí va a vender
un millón de hornos a 50 dólares cada
uno
así que obtendrá 50 millones de dólares
50 millones de dólares en ingresos que
querrá convertir ayudarles
y esto de aquí es el suministro de
dólares de eeuu
y vamos a suponer que estas son las
únicas personas que comercian con estas
monedas en nuestro mundo ultra
simplificado ahora el fabricante de eeuu
va a vender 2 millones de unidades a 60
yuanes cada una lo que serán 120
millones 120 millones de yuanes en
ingresos
los cuales querrá convertir en dólares a
la tasa actual de intercambio que es de
6 yenes por un dólar si dividimos esto
en 36 nos dará 20 millones 20 millones
de dólares obviamente este otro querrá
cambiar sus dólares ayudan es porque esa
es la moneda del lugar donde vive y allí
están sus costos lo mismo sucede con
este que quiere convertir sus jóvenes a
dólares porque es donde tiene o bien en
sus costos
este es el suministro de dólares que
quiere convertirse a moneda china esto
de aquí es la demanda de dólares esta es
la cantidad de dólares que necesita la
persona que quiere convertir sus juanes
a dólares aquí claramente hay un
desequilibrio el suministro de dólares
es mucho mayor que la demanda de dólares
en esta situación y en el momento en el
que el suministro de cualquier cosa sea
mayor que la demanda de esto
significa que el precio precio tiene que
bajar cuando hablamos del precio de una
moneda este es el caso del precio del
dólar lo hablamos en términos de yuanes
así que el dólar va a la baja
va a bajar lo que significa que el yuan
va a subir el yuan sube el dólar se
volverá más débil y el yuan se volverá
fuerte
si esto sucede quiere les pasará a los
precios de por acá si el yuan se
fortalece de manera que un dólar valga
cinco o cuatro yuanes o incluso tres
yuanes pues el fabricante chino no podrá
mantener el precio de 50 dólares por lo
que tendrá que aumentar el precio para
poder cubrir sus costos en moneda china
y si aumenta el precio va a disminuir la
demanda de su producto del otro lado de
la ecuación el fabricante estadounidense
para obtener la misma cantidad de
dólares puede vender más barato su
producto ahora necesitan menos yuanes
por cada dólar así que puede bajar el
precio en china lo cual aumentará la
demanda de su producto ahora lo que
sucede es que debido a que el yuan se
hizo más fuerte si tenemos una tasa de
intercambio flotante pues va a disminuir
la demás
de bienes chinos y aumentará la demanda
de bienes de eeuu
y eventualmente este desequilibrio
mercantil se solucionará por sí solo
esto es algo teórico porque en la
realidad no se permite el intercambio
flotante y hablaremos con más detalle de
esto en futuros vídeos